I think in your notes that you're.
Okay.
So, as in the past, do you use yourself and get things?
My name is Steve Lawson.
It's the 8th of November, 2011.
We're in a room in the Valley Library.
Okay.
So, our past interviews, we parked mainly by your way to the point.
I want to start doing, you know,
I'm talking with this interview.
And over the next seven years,
we've got a little talk about the experience.
Okay.
And so, I'm wondering,
because if you call anything about your initial interview,
then don't you ask them back in 1978?
Right.
After I graduated from college,
I spent a fairly parapotatic number of years traveling around the country.
Every visiting relatives and friends around the country
and finally came back to Palo Alto, California,
because I really truly loved the Bay Area at that time.
It was very exciting to Rific Environment.
I loved everything about California, in particular the Bay Area,
culturally or statistically,
intellectually and very stimulating environment.
So, I wanted to try to remain in the Bay Area possible.
Although I still at that point,
it was not very career oriented.
I didn't really have a very clear idea of what I wanted to do in the future.
At some point, and I'm not exactly sure how
I became aware of a listing for a position
at the one that's playing the Institute of Science in Medicine,
which at that time was located at 2700 San Hill Road
in Memo Park, just opposite Stanford,
linear accelerator, in an office building.
Up the street from Madison Wells Lee,
and a number of other publishing houses
that were located along that road at the time.
Property that was owned by Tom Ford,
who I believe was perhaps on the board justices of Stanford University
or large donors of Stanford University at the time.
So, it was in 1977 that I interviewed for a position at the Institute.
And the initial position was part-time.
And then in February of 1978,
it turned into a full-time salary position.
Initially, I interviewed with Korean Gorham,
I believe, who was the Secretary of the Institute
and head of HR department,
for whatever that was worth at the time,
fairly small organization still.
And I guess she was sufficiently impressed
to ask me to come back to meet with Art Robinson,
who was the President Director of the Institute.
And Art had recently, in 1976,
1977, set up a program of direct mail solicitation
in order to bolster the financial base of the Institute
because grants were very hard to come by.
And in particular, the work on Vitamin C,
that Linus Pauling felt so strongly about,
was very hard to fund.
So they turned to the public for funding source.
And that resulted in buying and trading mailing list
to primarily to magazines
that whose subscribers might be interested
in the mission and the work of the Linus Pauling Institute
magazines in particular, like Prevention,
which in those days had a much less pharmaceutical orientation
that it has today.
It was kind of a companion publication to Rodeals
organic farming and gardening magazine.
So I think Rodeal Press had kind of an
orthomolecular perspective on not just farming and gardening,
but also on health.
And in those days, they emphasize nutrition
and vitamin supplements and things like that.
So that seemed like a very lightly candidate
for raising money to support research efforts
and that program was very successful.
So it resulted in a tremendous amount of mail
and processing of donations.
So the job, the specific job that I interviewed for at that time,
had to do with,
that was related to this direct mail program,
processing of donations.
And also, initially, some fairly rudimentaries,
statistical analyses of the donations,
where they were coming from, the magnitude of donations,
what mailing lists were succeeding,
which were failing, and so forth.
So that was what I was doing initially.
What was your impression of the institution
for the directly adapted there?
Well, I thought the atmosphere at the Institute was quite collegial.
The Institute shared that building on San Hill Road
with Kemper insurance.
So the Institute did not have access to all the
rooms in the building.
And it was clear that what had been built
and designed as an office building had been renovated
to some extent to accommodate the Institute's research.
So it wasn't really laid out optimally as a research facility,
but nevertheless, I think they did a terrific job
of shoe-harning the various research programs
into the available space.
Well, I'd have to consult notes.
I can't remember how many square feet.
I know that the next facility on page mill road
for 40 page mill road was over 20,000 square feet.
So this facility was less than 20,000 square feet
available to the Institute.
And there were programs in metabolite profiling,
or metabolic profiling, under way,
as well as vitamin C and cancer,
and some other sundry studies that did not require
large laboratory facility.
There was a lot of chemical work on vitamin C
done by Connie Chow at the time under
Polling's direction, which didn't really require
a lot of floor space in a laboratory.
And then there were also animal experiments underway,
which did require quite a lot of square footage
to carry out.
And then of course there was the volcano source
field ionization mass spectrometer,
which was a lab unto itself.
And that was being developed by Bill Abert
who was a physicist, formerly an SRI,
which was near the US geographical survey,
geological survey facility in Menel Park.
And also I think originally had some
relationship with Stanford University,
but then had become independent.
That's where I actually learned to do so culture work.
When I set up the first so culture facility
at the Institute a while later.
I think that everybody seemed to be very friendly
and very dedicated to the work they were doing.
I was particularly struck by the dedication of art Robinson
and Rick Hicks, who was the Executive Vice President
in charge of fundraising.
And you and Cameron, who had come by from time to time,
who was a non-resident fellow.
I believe at the time.
And later became medical director of the Institute
and moved to California.
But in those days in San Hill Road,
he was still I believe non-resident fellow.
Carrying up the clinical collaboration with minus Paul
and Scotland.
And I would say that everyone was extremely enthusiastic
and dedicated.
It seemed to be a pretty cohesive group.
And that part of the ambience there really appealed to me.
So as far as a working environment,
it seemed to be quite good.
It wasn't until a little later that there was a schism
that developed between art Robinson and minus Paul
or things tended to become awkward
and sourd a little at that time.
What was Robinson?
You're actually delighted that one.
I would say he was.
Yes, he actually hired me.
I interviewed with him.
I found him to be a very intense, motivated person.
I liked him.
I thought his personality, as I said,
was quite intense.
But he seemed to be very bright,
very sharp, very insightful.
And I enjoyed working with him
and for him in the direct mail program.
Excuse me.
As this schism developed between Robinson and Paul
and Robinson was no longer physically present
in the Institute, I had been working.
Actually, I think, almost from the inception
of my employment at the Institute,
as time permitted in scientific operations,
Alan Sheets was a biochemist who was doing work on vitamin C
and also in the vitamin C and skin cancer experiments
that were being overseen by Robinson and Pauling at that time.
Alan and I really hit it all together
and liked to talk about science.
Of course, I had some background in science.
It's Stanford.
They were sometimes short-staffed in the scientific sector
and I would volunteer to do work with the animals
in the laboratory.
And I think I had an aptitude for that work
and some competence as well.
And that was recognized by Alan and Dick will be
another people who were involved in that realm at the time.
So, gradually, my responsibilities,
my activity shifted from the direct mail campaign
to working as a research assistant
in the laboratory environment.
I'm the old Zudrkello,
I am in the February 1977 McLean Institute.
What was the goal at that time?
A meal had been a non-resident fellow.
I believe of the Institute and then joined the Institute
to work with Pauling and to continue independent work
on the journal Molecular Evolution,
which he was the founding editor of.
And he had some pretty interesting ideas
that were mainly theoretical in nature.
And so, I mean, it didn't really need a laboratory
to carry out his work at the time.
Of course, he and Pauling had known each other for a very long time.
The Zudrkello I believe had been at Caltech.
And the two of them had developed this concept
of chemical paleogenetics,
or molecular evolution in probably the late 50s,
or early 60s, was published in the early 1960s,
which Francis Crick thought was one of Pauling's major achievements.
And I think actually most of it was probably due to Zudrkello's ideas,
but nevertheless, together they developed this very interesting idea
of dating the divergence of species,
based upon similarities in hemoglobin,
which are shared in a molecule which shared them
for many million species for the great species.
A meal was a very interesting,
very kindly person.
He was definitely European in nature,
and seemed to be extremely intelligent.
A meal was one of the rare individuals
who could hold many competitive ideas
in his mind simultaneously and expound upon each of them in turn.
So I found him very, a very challenging intellect,
and I really enjoyed talking with him.
Sometime later I started working,
I was working for different groups within the Institute,
all of which were quite small,
and a meal and I got along so well
that a meal wanted me to do more and more work with him.
This was after he became President Director of the Institute
after the departure of Art Robinson.
And that led to kind of a long collaboration
with a meal that culminated in my appointment
as a co-director of the laboratory
for research and gene regulation in the mid-1980s.
A meal at that time was very interested in cancer metastasis
and what genes, what proteins were involved
in the development of that phenotype,
because many people who suffer and die from cancer
will die from metastatic involvement.
Even if the primary tumor is surgically treated,
or treated successfully with radiation and chemotherapy,
it's often not possible to kill all the metastatic cells
that can move through the lymph system or through the blood system
and colonize other tissues.
So a meal was very interested in that,
and we set up a program at the Institute
to use a technique called two-dimensional polycholomy gel electrophoresis.
Excuse me, to profile proteins,
present in tumor cells and metastatic tumor cells
related to the primary tumor and also normal tissue
to look for proteins that might be involved
and therefore genes that might be involved in the development
of this phenotype.
And I think a meal had the idea at that time
that these might be regulatory proteins,
which would be present in very small amounts in cells.
So we had to set up a cell culture laboratory, which I did,
bought all the equipment, read a lot about tissue culture
and what was important and what kind of equipment would be appropriate.
Learn the techniques at SRI,
and also learn some techniques at UCSD
and University of Colorado in Boulder about to find media
because we were very interested in eliminating
or perhaps eliminating it's not the right word,
and we went into the greatest extent possible
the amount of noise in the system.
And we wanted to increase reproducibility
of our protein profile as well
because if regulatory proteins are involved in this process
of metastatic cancer,
then we need to be able to detect them.
And to detect them,
we need to increase reproducibility
and decrease noise in the system.
So I spent quite a lot of time
with my colleague Stuart McGuire
and Eddie Metz and Mark Pack and others
in trying to perfect that system.
So was it the kind of main aim
that pretty active research program
even though he was listening more and more
at Metastatic cancer as well?
He did.
That's right.
He did assume more and more administrative load.
Pauling, of course,
I think had plenty of aptitude for administration
but was less interested in administration.
Pauling really wanted to concentrate on a theoretical work,
his clinical work,
the vitamin C work,
or the molecular medical work.
And Suka Kondo,
from a research perspective,
was probably a little broader
in what he wanted the institute to become.
And as his influence in administration increased
and the funding available to the institute increased,
the focus of the institute also broadened
to be much more kind of a molecular biological approach
to health and disease rather than specifically focused
on North and Molecular Medicine.
So, for instance, the program that I was involved in
looking at gene regulation and cancer
really had nothing to do specifically
with North and Molecular Medicine and Nutrition.
So, I think Emil had a vision for the institute
as something like the Salk Institute in Mahalia
or the Institute that he had founded in France
and left before he joined the line
in his Polynes Institute of Science in Medicine,
which was much more of a molecular biological approach
to science.
The mission is intelligence,
how will you characterize this personality?
Well, I think that he was very kinetic,
he's very tall, lean person,
had a lot of physical energy,
as well as mental stamina and vigor.
And also had a very European attitude about things.
I think in some ways the served him well
and in some ways it may not have served him terribly well
because the administration of the institute
became a little bit of a black box
and perhaps was not quite as transparent
as it could have been that would have promoted
better relations among employees much later
in the history of the institute.
And this is an extension of the European attitude.
I think so.
I mean it's hard to say I'm not a psychologist
and I don't know that much about
European political systems
but I think Emil was kind of a benevolent king.
Well, at the more personal or social level
we have mental interactions with the people that come to mind.
Well, I had many, many interactions
with Emil over the years.
He had a terrific sense of humor
and not so much in a joke telling way
but a good sense of irony
and we got along very, very well.
And I think Emil depended upon me
and Eddie Metz, who was another research associate
to answer to.
And a number of other people within his group
to help him make decisions about hiring,
for instance.
So there were a number of people who came to the institute
and went through a review process
candidates for certain positions
and Eddie Metz and myself and some others
I think played pretty critical roles
in those processes at the time
because Emil rightly or wrongly
I think trusted my judgment about people
and I would give him very candid observations
to the best extent I could
about potential candidates
for positions within the institute.
We also shared an appreciation of art
so Emil and his wife Jane
lived in a penthouse apartment
on a raster deero in Palo Alto
and I was relatively frequent guest
and we would talk about art, talk about Emil's heritage,
his ancestors, his grandparents, his parents were all
very famous in the respective fields
both in psychology, psychoanalysis, anatomy, art
and I remember one time Emil showed me
he was a bit embarrassed about it
because it's not something that has a lot of
objective value but he knew I would be interested
in his autograph book
which he had maintained as a kid
in his grandmother's salon
and had signatures in this book
from Sigmund Freud
and a number of other very famous people musicians
and scientists, I can't recall exactly who now
but it was pretty impressive to see at the time
was he a cognitive audience?
I don't think he had the financial
wherewithal to collect art
but he had had art that he inherited from the family
and Emil's family was Jewish
and had lived in both Austria, Vienna and France
and during the Nazi occupation
and Nazi infiltration of countries in Europe
his family was forced to flee
and often fled without their possession
so I know many years later he showed me a catalog
of German art and architecture
in which his parents chairs were featured
and these were chairs that were part of
the old Zupacondal home
that they'd been forced to abandon
when the Nazis arrived
and he had remnants of some art
that he'd been able to take with him
Gustav Klimt, triptych and things like that
which I think he'd given away actually at that time
but he did have some art and some books
that managed to survive that ugly process in Europe
Okay, well I want to talk about our Robinson
and then it's your first of all
knowing what your sense of being as a scientist
was when you initially met Emil after moving
Yeah, that's a good question
I would say that I did not have enough science
at that time to offer any judgment on art Robinson
I knew that he was working very closely with Linus Polling
so I assumed that he must be brilliant
because I doubted that Linus Polling would tolerate fools
and research was clearly the most important thing
in Polling's life, research and science
and I just imagine that art Robinson
must be a terrifically intelligent person
working with Linus Polling because otherwise he wouldn't be
at the Institute
He seemed to have Polling's trust
and many people had pretty high regard for art Robinson
called him kind of the boy Wonder
He was quite young at that time as well
maybe in his 30s I believe
when he was president director of the Institute
so he'd come up from UCSD to take a position
in Polling's lab at Stanford
and then together with King Dimit co-founded
the Institute
while the Institute was still located at Stanford
and then when they were able to secure
a rental site in this building on San Hill Road
and they moved physically the Institute
transferred the grants to the San Hill Road location
I had a very favorable impression of art
I liked him quite a lot
and he seemed to be incredibly driven
I didn't know at that time anything
about his politics, his religion
or anything I never asked him about those things
I never talked to them about those things
it was all strictly science
but I really enjoyed my interactions with him at that time
and I was not high enough up in the food chain
the bureaucracy within the Institute
to really understand at the time
the nature of the conflict that developed
between art Robinson and Linus Polling
so I was completely in the dark
as to why that developed and why art left the Institute
but there were a series of very
bewildering memos at that time
I remember after art left
and of course there was gossip about
what was going on and who was in charge
and what had happened and so forth
I can't really remember the gossip very clearly
but I do remember coming into my office one day
and finding a memo from Linus Polling
a couple of short paragraphs explaining that art Robinson
had absented himself from the Institute
and was no longer serving as a president
director, Linus Polling was taking over that position
and I should ignore
directives from art Robinson
that was followed the next day
by a memo from art Robinson
the effect that Linus Polling had no authority
to remove from his position
disregard the earlier memo from Linus Polling
and things like that went back and forth for a while
so it was a period of tension
to say the least at the Institute
people were a little bewildered as to what to do
but I think ultimately because Linus Polling
was chairman of the board
and the Institute was named for him
and I think people just inferred
that Linus Polling was in charge
and therefore Linus Polling was the one who
had the authority to say on what the status of art Robinson
was at that time
So when you think about a Robinson
as a personality in intense peace and view
or that comes to life
Yes, he was very intense, very driven
no question about that
and he had a very robust family life
I mean he was very
his wife, Laura Lee Robinson
at the time was working at the Institute
in the data acquisition
and analysis from the metabolic profiling program
so she was there quite often
she was a very lovely person
I liked her very much as well
and together they seemed like a very good pair
very happy married couple
it was quite a shock when she died so suddenly
and art of course had small children
that he had to turn his attention to and to raise
and it just seemed like a very stressful time
for everyone
the combination of Laura Lee's
very abrupt death
art having these young kids to take care of now
and also having this problem with Linus Polling
and essentially losing his job at the Institute
I do remember
that prior to this schism with Linus Polling
there had been several meetings
in the Institute's library
about the future at the Institute
and the prospect of moving to Oregon
had been raised by our Robinson specifically at that time
the late 1970s
Art had talked about property in Oregon
and if my memory serves me
I think it was near Eugene or Junction City
that might be available at low cost
for the Institute to buy
and build a building and set up laboratories there
and I think that there was an informal poll
taken amongst staff as to whom
I'd be interested in relocating to Oregon at that time
not many people weren't
Do you know anything more about where
this idea came from along Oregon?
I don't
But I should say also that when the schism
between Polling and Art developed
it occurred to me that that might have been one of the factors
that led to this problem
because Polling of course had a very close relationship
with friends and faculty at Stanford
still, Hard McConnell
and we tab a number of other people
in the chemistry department there and elsewhere
you had homes in Portola Valley and Big Sur
and it didn't seem to me that he would want
at his age and station in life to move to Oregon
and I was never at that time I wondered
whether that was part of the problem
that had developed between them
So in hindsight, did you have any other
thoughts on what life was given?
Well, when I became chief executive officer
or executive officer in the Linus Plan Institute
in the early 1990s
I was talking about the Institute
before lots of groups quite often
and consequently I had to familiarize myself
pretty quickly with the history of the Institute
and some of the major figures in the Institute
so I really had to learn a lot more about Linus
Polling his career than I previously had known
and I had to learn about art Robinson
and some of the activities
that had transpired over the Institute over the years
so I looked at some of the depositions
I looked at the court papers that were now available
to me as executive officer
and I read that material quite carefully at the time
because I wanted to be able to represent the story accurately
and to the best of my ability
so I thought it was incumbent upon me to learn
as much as I could about that problem
that developed between Robinson and Polling
so that I would have a good understanding of it
and I wouldn't be simply melving some person's opinion
of what had happened
but I'd actually formed an opinion myself
based on original research
into the raw data if you will
and that led me to the conclusion
that there were administrator problems
that had developed between Robinson and Polling
it didn't have anything to do with the results
from the vitamin C and skin cancer experiments
as far as I could tell as Art Robinson portrayed
the whole problem
Art said that the anomalous results
at low dose supplemental vitamin C
that actually resulted in increased
number of tumors in these hairless mice
exposed to ultraviolet light
if
if you extrapolated that to people
it would be people would be at risk
for developing cancer
let's say skin cancer in this case
after doses of supplementary vitamin C
that Polling was recommending for good health
but there was a significant problem
in that argument
and the problem is that mice synthesize vitamin C
and I believe even Art himself
at the time had suggested that the exogenous vitamin C
given in the diet to these mice
might have affected their endogenous synthesis
of vitamin C
especially at low dose
and Connie Chow and a number of other people
paying loan
at the institute looked into that
four line is pond very carefully
and found that sure enough
when you give small extra doses of vitamin C to mice
you actually decrease the amount of vitamin C
in blood and various organs and tissues
compared to the mice getting no extra vitamin C
and you actually have to overcome that
by giving much larger amounts of vitamin C
and then you start to see increases in vitamin C
in these various tissues and organs
and the blood
and also protection against the development of skin cancer
caused by exposure to ultraviolet light
so it has nothing to do with people
because we don't synthesize vitamin C
so supplemental vitamin C doesn't interfere
with anything that we're doing
or delivers unlike the mice
so that argument that art put forward
to explain this problem with lion's pollen
didn't seem to hold water to me
and I looked more carefully at some of the administrative decisions
that would be made at that time
specifically with respect to Richard Hicks
and affiliation with a group in Santa Cruz
the Hansburgers
that pollen was not very happy about
and Hansburgers were very interested in wheatgrass
and abscystic acid
as having cancer prevention
or therapeutic properties
and some experiments
along those lines were carried out at the Institute
where wheatgrass was being fed
to mice to find out if it could protect them against cancer
but pollen I think and I never talked to him about this
but inferring from what I read
it seemed to me that he was concerned about
somewhat flaky character of this operation
in Santa Cruz
and he was worried about a close affiliation
because the work that he was already advocating
and trying to get funded seemed to be very controversial anyway
and I don't think he wanted to encourage
even more skepticism about the Institute's activities
by getting associated with
fringe or what he might consider fringe organizations
Robinson had a different perspective
and also I think pollen had set up
an executive committee composed of himself
Rick Hicks and Art
and I believe that Art was asked not to make any important decisions
without approval of these executive committee
and Art essentially ignored that
and wanted to fire Rick Hicks
and pollen liked Hicks
and thought he was doing a good job
so I think that the conflict that developed between them
had to do with administrative issues
had to run and govern the line as plans
to science and medicine, not scientific issues
I don't really think that Robins
I don't really think that Robinson was unhappy with Hicks' performance
and maybe Hicks had not done some things that Robins
and expected him to do or it asked him to do
they also had very different personalities
and they could have been a bit of a personality clash there as well
So how did the legal ring link play out?
The legal ring link play out?
It was a multi-year affair, it was very distracting
to all involve very expensive proposition
there were lots of suits, of course at that time
I didn't really involve myself with any of that
because I had no administrative functions
I was just happy doing my research
not worrying about what was going on
in the legal realm
or the administrative hierarchy of the institute
but I'm looking back at these documents retrospectively
and clear that people were completely subsumed
with these legal issues
because when these kinds of charges are made and suits are filed
you really have to do the best you can to protect the organization
and that means hiring good attorneys
and getting into the details of all the issues
and countless depositions and document analyses
and it's all very tedious and very expensive
In a way it's also quite fascinating
because jurisprudence is a very interesting game
legal game that gets played
and it's interesting to see how the strategies evolve
and how the players behave
but it can be incredibly distracting
if your main goal is to carry out research
and I think it was very distracting for everybody involved
and art ended up suing his attorneys
because he was unhappy with the settlement
that had eventually been reached
and sometime much later
I think between the time I became chief executive officer
and Linus Pong's death
Art Robinson reemerged from the past
and really I had nothing to do with him
and hadn't heard from him or about him for many, many years
because after the settlement in the early 1980s
that was the end of the legal entanglement
with our Robinson I knew that he had moved to Oregon
to cave junction and set up his own research organization
that wasn't quite sure exactly what he was doing
this was long before the internet of course
and it was difficult to fared out details about
because activities unlike today
so I really had no reason to think about our Robinson
until I got a phone call or a letter
actually it was a letter I believe
asked to Linus Pong from Art that Pong turned over to me
that was a request for access to research data
that Art had generated at the Institute
before his departure
so Art described this research data
as being many filing the five
the steel case five drawer filing cabinets
maybe ten or fifteen of those
worth of hard copy paper records
that were generated as a result of the metabolic
profiling program
and also very large magnetic data tapes
that were maybe a foot in diameter
and at the time without going back and actually looking
at the terms of the settlement
which of course stipulated that none of that had to be given to our Robinson
and he had already been given an opportunity to copy
his research data
albeit at high cost
before he left the Institute he declined to do so at that time
but I thought all these years had gone by
there was really nothing to be gained
and withholding anything from Art Robinson
and if he was able to
if he was able to translate this raw data
into scientific publications
that would be scientifically or medically valuable
I was in favor of that
so I decided to look around and see
what I could find that was
that resembled what he'd asked for
and in looking around the Institute
I could find nothing
that resembled the volume of material that he had requested
there weren't boxes and boxes
or many filing cabinets full of data
there weren't dozens or hundreds of magnetic data tapes
these things just didn't exist within the building
so I queried a number of people including
Dick Willoughby who was our facility's manager
and he was at the Institute at that time
and a number of other people who I thought
might have had some knowledge of the whereabouts of this material over time
no one really seemed to have a clear idea of what had happened to it
but I reconstructed what I believe to be
its disposition and I sent this and a letter
Robinson, what I considered a very collegial cordial letter
I mean it was unhappy news for Robinson
but nevertheless it was as far as I knew
and as far as I still know the truth
about the disposition of this material
the Institute had a satellite facility
on Porter Drive in Stanford, Industrial Park
and that satellite facility was used for
Sussacala aging research
that was carried out by Jim Fleming and others
also in the 1980s we had carried out some work
on fabricating superconductive material
to support one of Pauling's patent application,
Stella Kerman and to some extent you and Cameron
and I worked on that project
and we also used a number of rooms there for paper storage
and we'd had problems with the roof leaking in that facility
that actually led to a lawsuit with a landlord
and a lot of the paper that had been stored in that facility
was ruined because the leak of the roof leaked
and the paper was damaged by water
and I believe there was just thrown out
and because it was damaged there wasn't any attempt
made to really examine it carefully
I'm reconstructing that, I don't know that for sure
but I do know because I did see it with my own eyes
a lot of destroyed records
by water
and then I gave that as what I considered
a reasonable explanation of what had happened
to our research material
my understanding was that it had been stored up there
because there wasn't any room to really keep it
in the 440 page mill road facility
if indeed it had been kept that long
it was a quarter drive and probably destroyed by water
from a leaking roof
that as I said led to litigation with a landlord
because the landlord wasn't quick
in repairing the roof unfortunately
so art did not take that news very well
and in a way I can sympathize with it
because that work represented a significant
percent of his life's work at that time
but that's the way it is
the material was gone
it was probably destroyed, probably damaged
and there was nothing to give him
but he was unwilling to accept that explanation
and believed for whatever reason very obscured me
that I must be hiding this material
or lying to him
mischaracterizing everything
and I tried to think about what is motivation
for believing that I would do that
and I just could not come up with a sensible motivation
I think that he played so much emphasis
on the importance of this material
that it was beyond comprehension
to him that it could have been thrown away
even having been damaged
so he was unwilling to accept that explanation
and that led to kind of a proxy lawsuit
against the Institute by a colleague of his Jane Orient
who I think is associated with him
and kind of libertarian politics
and she's a physician in Arizona
at least at the time
who had made rather strategically
I believe a small donation to the Institute
and then later wanted access to research records
and she called me on the telephone
and I had a nice conversation with her
and she was asking about research
and at first I was confused
I thought she was talking about the protein profiling work
and then I realized she was talking about the metabolic profiling work
and I talked about some of the work
that had been ongoing until the mid 1980s and so forth
the development of the apparatus
and data collection and analysis
and loss of funding and so forth
and then it became clear that what she was really interested in
was this old art Robinson material
and I think at the time I told her
the same thing I told her
which is I don't know what happened to it
we don't have it
so I can't offer it to you
so that led to a suit that she filed
against the Institute for access
to this publicly financed research data
and that of course involved a lot of time
and energy and resources
but eventually it was dismissed by the court
for lack of standing, essentially
Do you have a sense of what's in your range
or the reconciliation involved in the following report?
Well I think art's letter to Linus Pauling
and Linus Pauling's response to him
if there was a response was cordial
Art's letter was pretty cordial
I don't know that they communicated much
from the time the lawsuit finished
until that letter in the early 1990s
my guess is they probably did not
because art really in many occasions
have lots of bad things to say about the Institute
and Linus Pauling
so I can't imagine that they really communicated much
and I don't know that that was art's attempted reconciliation
or whether he viewed that opportunity
of me being in charge in the Institute now
and Pauling gradually expiring
as an opportunity to get access
to research data that he thought we've been sitting on
all those years.
Okay, well let's switch to you
and everyone.
He read from 1978
perhaps in the full time
but he was a wonderful person.
He was very charming.
He had a great sense of humor.
He also had the Scottish broke
and was shy, I think.
He didn't like to talk in public
and it sometimes was hard to understand what he was saying
because of his accent and a tendency
to mumble sometimes.
But he was very intelligent, very compassionate.
Clearly a research minded physician
who was interested in finding new ways
to help his patients live with cancer.
I think he and Pauling initially
thought that vitamin C might
might be able to turn cancer into a manageable disease.
A chronic disease rather than something
that would kill you in short order
and that led him to consider vitamin C as
having potential value and treating cancer patients.
I really enjoyed him.
I would go to parties with him quite often.
He loved to drink single malt scotch
which he would bring from every time he went
to Scotland and came back.
He would always have a seem like an arm load
of single malt scotchers for everyone to try.
And he liked his mugs cigarettes too
which was a bit ironic.
Sometimes it's the old do as I say
that not as I do motif that you see
sometimes with physicians or other people.
Cameron was not pious.
He didn't preach to people about
what they should or shouldn't do.
And he was well aware of his own
bad habit of smoking.
It was hard to reconcile with his
career as a cancer surgeon
removing disease lungs
and other tissue from patients.
Nevertheless, he found it very difficult to quit.
I know he tried to quit smoking
in a number of times but didn't succeed.
So I kind of, I think I kind of liked him
because he had some weaknesses as well
but he was extremely bright
and very compassionate person.
And he party settings.
He was a more thoughtful person.
He party settings. He was more social.
Yeah, he was very social.
Very, very social.
My girlfriend and I loved to hear him tell tales
about his work in Burma.
I remember one story he told about
lancing a boil on an elephant
which was quite extraordinary.
And he told me about some of the
therapy available to the cohort of
cancer patients that he was treating
which was called Brompton's Cocktail
which was a mixture of
I believe alcohol, cocaine, and heroin
that's got its surgeons and physicians
very freely gave to their terminal cancer
patients because they weren't concerned
about these people becoming drug addicts.
They just wanted to make their
end of their lives as comfortable
and pain-free as possible.
The following ever coming
on camera to you
and is a personal feeling for some of these professional
feelings.
Pauling really liked you and Cameron.
I think he had a very deep feeling for you and Cameron
and despite the fact that Cameron smoked
Pauling was apparently willing to completely
overlook that.
And Pauling felt very strongly about smoking.
I remember seeing letters that were unopened
in Dorothy Monroe's office
because they smelled of cigarette smoke
and Pauling refused to handle them.
So that didn't seem to bother him so much
about you and Cameron though and they were
they were a great colleagues.
I think they enjoyed each other's company quite a lot
and Cameron regaled us with stories
my girlfriend and I about to
Pauling's first visit to Scotland.
I didn't mention this in the last talk today.
The toilets, did I mention that?
Yeah.
So Cameron was very down to Earth
and very much aware of Pauling's reputation
and stature in the scientific field too.
So Cameron himself was a little bit
in awe of Pauling but Cameron had
medical knowledge of course that Pauling
didn't so they provided kind of a nice
complementary relationship for each other I think.
And I think as a result of working
with Cameron for so long, Pauling became
even more medically minded.
And I know that Abram Hoffer,
another of Pauling's old friends who initially
got him interested in nice and
and Northam molecular psychiatry
back in early 1960s, told me that he had been working
hard towards the end of Pauling's life
to get him an honorary medical degree
which apparently is possible in Canada
being part of the United Kingdom.
You can appeal to the Archbishop of Cancerbury
I believe through the Duke of Winds
or something like that to get a medical degree
conferred upon someone.
Of course, it wouldn't allow them to practice medicine
but it was a very prestigious honor
and Hoffer was working
those channels because he knew the English royalty
that would do it help him with this process
but then he dropped it once Pauling died of course.
I like Cameron's family.
I did.
It did not meet Cameron's first wife,
a new Connie Cameron, his second wife quite well
because she had been working for Rick Hicks at the Institute
and that's how you and Cameron got to know her
through his visits and tenure
at the Linus Pauling Institute and she also
a very charming, very funny, attractive person.
You and had a son and a daughter
and he was always a bit concerned about his son
because his son seemed to be having a bit of a hard time
being independent, finding a career,
being happy with his life and so forth.
You and was also conflicted a bit
in taking the position at the Institute in California
because it would take him away from his children
and he was concerned that his children still needed some guidance.
But I met his children, they were very nice people,
very affable, very intelligent,
very curious people.
So how did Cameron's research program
of all over the course of this time of institute?
Well, I would say when he was physically
at the Institute, he of course was not
treating patients in Scotland
but he was continuing to collect and analyze data
from those cancer cases in Scotland
and continuing to work with
people who were doing that for him in Scotland
developing ways of analyzing the data,
automated data collections, programs and things
of that nature.
So he was very involved in that while he was at the Institute.
He also became increasingly involved in
what today is called Outreach
or public education.
And as the work with Cameron and Pauling
on Vitamin C and Cancer became more well known,
there were many queries from the public,
particularly patients afflicted with cancer,
who wanted advice.
How much vitamin C should I take?
Where can I go to get it and so on and so forth?
There had been a clinic operating at the Institute
on San Hill Road for a very short period
but it became overburden by poor patients
very quickly.
So that was a band and that was set up by John Catchpool.
And like I said, didn't last very long.
So we were struggling at the time
between giving sensible, practical and non-medical
advice to people because Cameron wasn't licensed
to practice medicine in the United States
so he couldn't give medical advice to people.
So we had to be a bit oblique about it
and provide patients and their physicians with research papers
and a mood to responses of other similar patients
to a certain course of therapy and so forth.
So Cameron was working very hard
to kind of perfect our strategy of responding
to the public for these health related questions
so that we didn't incur legal liability
but we were acting ethically and morally
and trying to be good citizens and compassionate
because many of the people who contacted the Institute
and those days were in dire straits.
These were people for whom traditional conventional therapy
was not successful and they were just waiting to die
and they weren't willing to accept that fate
so they were turning to other modalities
which included things like vitamin C
and once they started to consider that naturally
the tendency was to get in touch with the Institute
and talk to you and Cameron.
So he spent an enormous amount of time on the phone
and writing letters to cancer patients
and had the people of questions about vitamin C.
Well Cameron and Pauline's research on cancer
attracted the great deal of criticism
that you have a sense of how they respond back and finally.
Yeah, I think they felt
and this has been written about many times
and I think you can infer their emotions
from some of the letters that appeared in journals and elsewhere
that they had been treated badly
by the male clinic
and both Cameron and Pauline were astonished
to find out and angry
that the male clinic researchers Craig and Mortel
had never even read Cameron's papers, relevant papers.
So they ostensibly were charged by the NCI
with replicating Cameron's work
yet they knew virtually nothing about it
and had they read Cameron's papers
they may have noticed that Cameron was giving high dose
vitamin C both orally and intravenously
and that, as it turns out, may have been a very crucial feature
that was completely ignored by them
because they perhaps had too much hubris
to read this Scottish surgeon's papers
on vitamin C and cancer.
And I think the fact that the studies were published
without the courtesy of showing the study
before publication to Pauline and Cameron
did not sit well with them
because once the study was published
immediately the media wants responses
the same day
and it put you in an awkward position
because Cameron and Pauline had that a time
to read the study and think about it carefully
and come up with a cogent analysis
and critique of it
so they were angered by that
as well because they felt that professional courtesy
was not extended to them in that regard
and they felt that the work that the Mayo Clinic had done
was to use Pauline's word somewhat fraudulent
and they were worried that this would end
serious consideration of vitamin C
as injunctive therapy for cancer
and they felt that that would be unethical
and immoral
and unscientific and ill conceived
so they were upset
and it was clear that they were upset
and Cameron neither Cameron nor Pauline were
they didn't reveal anger
they didn't shout or break things or storm around
or anything like that
but voices were raised definitely
and Cameron was not very pleased
by the work that had been done at the Mayo Clinic
it showed
I think everyone was unhappy and angry as well
I think everyone shared the anger
that the studies had been published
and they weren't carefully done
and there seemed to be lots of problems with them
that they didn't replicate Cameron's protocol
as they reportedly did
and I think there was also concern
among the fundraising staff that this might
build ill for continuing efforts
to raise money to support research at the Institute
and sure enough, there were some fundraising problems
after that work was published
so it had a big impact on our work
at the Institute
as well as sort of shelving
serious consideration of vitamin C and cancer
for many, many years
which I think was a real disservice
to the research community
and to the huge population of cancer patients
out there who might have benefited from this
had the research been done more carefully
early on
but was that
I believe in the site
and believe in the idea
yes
and I think partly because the arguments
that both Cameron and Pauline
loved against male clinic researchers
were very cogent and sensible
they weren't just
you know, fringe arguments that had no validity
so they were valid arguments
and I think everyone was well aware of them
in Cameron I think
Cameron made
I think he said one time
at first he thought they were just dealing with fools
and then he realized they were dealing with naves
as he put it
the mission very briefly
in 1970
the clinic
or the cancer students
at the clinic for diagnosing
and treating these in the hospital
and talking a little bit more about that
well it predated my arrival
at the Institute
so I don't really have a lot of first-hand knowledge
about the clinic
I know that
the concept there was
was clear
that some people might benefit
from Orthodox and medical treatment
but I think the funding
and liability issues were
the funding was too low
and the liability issues were too
great
to really
turn that into a practical
functional concern
and I do remember
Korean Gorem and others telling me
that there were people who showed up
knocking on the door
definitely ill
and spent their last money on a bus ticket
to get there
and no money and expected to be cured
and that was not uncommon
and that of course just was not possible
so I think rather than
risk having the tailwag
the dog
they decided to dissolve the clinic
rather quickly
it was located within the building
as I understand
Frank has pool was part of that
Frank catch pool was part of that
and catch pool
I got to know often on
because even when the clinic finished
he was still loosely involved
with the Institute from time to time
and I think he was practicing
right up until the end of his life
in Marine County
maybe in Sossolido, California
and he really liked Pauling
and I think Pauling really liked him
quite a lot as well
he spoke at Pauling's memorial service
at Stanford Church
Did you ever talk about his life
but quite negative
I probably talked to him about his work in Africa
of course where I think Pauling first was met him
Albert Schweizer's camp there
I can't remember those discussions
very carefully now though
Well we talked about this kind of off the line
throughout the interview
but I'm wondering if you could be quite a little bit more
than kind of the chronic funny problems
in Kansas to face the very long time
Yeah well the Institute was I think founded and moved
off the campus of Stanford University
initially because there wasn't enough money
Nor was there enough space
at Stanford to carry out the work
that Pauling really felt would make a big impact
and public health
namely research and worth
molecules of medicine
and specifically research on vitamin C
and I think Pauling
and Robinson felt that this had great potential
as to metabolite profiling
metabolic profiling program
So they moved they founded the Institute moved to the
location that we've talked about in Menlo Park
and then said about trying to raise money
to carry out this research
and government grants were not
forthcoming for the vitamin C work
although the metabolic profiling work
was supported to a large extent
by government grants in those days
the development of the apparatus
data analysis data collection
sample collection things like that
and then as the Institute started to grow
the need for more resources
financial resources became pretty clear
and that's when Art Robinson
and Rick Hicks got involved in this direct mail
solicitation program
because they correctly perceived that the public
had responded to Pauling's message
and thoughts about vitamin C and health
much more quickly than the medical community
and scientific community so
there were lots of people out there
who believed that Pauling was right about vitamin C
and wanted to sort of support the David versus the Goliath
Pauling versus the convention
and the conventional medical establishment
so they were willing to give
small and large donations
to support research at the Institute
so in a way that was very good
because it allowed the Institute to hire staff scientists
without tenure of course
but hire them and provide them with money
to carry out research
that was not dependent on government grants
or corporate sponsorship
although throughout the history of the Institute
corporate sponsorship and contracts
were quite variable
Hoffman, Mirose, gave money
the Japan ship building industry foundation gave money
so there were
the record and organizational sources of funding
but sometimes they were restricted
and sometimes they were non-restricted
luckily the money from some of those large donors
was unrestricted and to be applied
across the board to support whatever line is Pauling
art Robinson or Amyles who could kind of felt was important
but because of excuse me
because of the stock market performance
and the vagaries of the national economy over years
that affected the ability of individuals
and to some extent corporations to give money
it affected their philanthropic abilities
so when there were down times during recessions
and other down times people gave less money
nevertheless at the Institute
the costs were constant or increasing
so in those times there was always a pinch
and that would often be resolved
transiently by decreasing contributions
to pension plans
or salary reductions
that were temporary
and they would be lifted
once the economic picture brightened somewhat
so it was always kind of a roller coaster
depending upon what was going on in the national economy
because when you're a charitable organization
depending upon the philanthropy of others
the economic climate effects
the ability to give
and we certainly were aware of that
much later as I said when the male clinic studies
on vitamin C and cancer were published
that also caused transient loss
in funds available to me
because people were giving less money
because they felt now vitamin C had failed
to show anything for why support that kind of research
and still later when people became aware
of polling interest and work in HIV
infection, AIDS, and vitamin C
that also caused a transient loss
in support because people were
some people were opposed to that work on moral grounds
and didn't want to see that kind of research funded at the Institute
I don't think there were
and interestingly enough
in the early 1990s
John Levitt who had been the director
of the molecular carcinogenesis laboratory
calculated the impact factor for the institution
so impact factors to be calculated
the journals they can be calculated for scientists
they can also be calculated for institutions
and I believe the result of John's analysis
at that time
ranked the Institute in the top 15
non-profit biomedical research institutes
in the country
on the basis of impact factor
and I should add that that was not all
related to Linus Polling's productivity
lots of papers from institute staff
figured in the calculation of the impact factor
so despite the fact that there were financial problems
throughout the Institute's career
I think ultimately in terms of productivity
and influence I think it succeeded
surprisingly well given the
its size and lack of resources
well we're at 65 minutes
do you want to do more questions here?
okay
what time is it?
it's 11.35
yeah a couple more questions
sound good
so in 1980 the Institute moved
in the middle of Part 440 page
and all of them
well my understanding at the time
was that the building
owned by Tom Ford
in which the Institute had been located
was primarily an office building
and it was on
loosely packed
sedimentary
soils
and over time
because earthquake activity
related to the San Andreas Falls
seismic activity in that whole area
there had been some structural problems
with the building
and I believe that the
owner wanted
to evict everyone
to fix the building
structurally
and probably did not want to invite the Linus
to back because he could make
much more money
by renting
that space to
paper companies
or
you know people who weren't doing lab research
and who's financial outlook
was sometimes sketchy
at best
so that
that precipitated a search
by Institute administrators
Rick Hicks
and in the Institute
of Contal in particular
to find a facility
in which the Institute
got research
which led them to this old battery factory
Cinderblock construction
at 440 page mill road
that didn't require
a great deal of renovation
in order to accommodate the Institute's work
there was some renovation
in laboratories
we had a class biological clean room
that we had to
design for large-scale
rat
mouse work
of a variant
where we were
housing guinea pigs
and other animals
for some vitamins
research
so
the move was made to that facility
and
we were on very good terms with the new landlords
who increased the rent
only dependent on the
CPI increase every year
every couple years
so
they weren't
out to make a killing
by escalating the rent
to the point
where we would have to move
and they would get some other tenant
and they seem to have
some feeling for the Institute's mission
and admiration for Lines Polling
and wanted to make it as
easy as possible for the Institute
to remain in that building
so it sounds like
in financial terms of this building
that positive move
mentioned in the space itself
what we're doing
well
it was
there was much more square footage
available to us in this building
the building itself
was
pretty shabby compared to the nice office building
that we
left
in Memo Park
as I said it was a
cinder block construction
kind of an ugly building
really nothing to look at
definitely not a showcase building
but it was functional
and the offices were fine
and we were able to carry out the scientific work
so
that was fine
it suited us at the time
and we moved
everything ourselves
Alan Sheetz
who was a biochemist working in the Institute
his father
had been a professional mover
in Idaho
and Alan had spent
a lot of his boyhood years
and college years
to several jobs moving
for his father's company
so he really knew
about moving equipment
and offices and laboratories
and so forth so Alan
really
coordinated our move
from one facility to the other
and we rented a bunch of
big trucks
and hand trucks
and blankets
and all the other
material that we needed to move
and basically did it ourselves
I saved a lot of money
for their
special consideration
that would suit the
apparatus
oh yeah
yeah everything was moved
very carefully of course
and we had to close
the experimental work
and then
locked down all the instruments
and it was a challenge to move
some of these things
but nevertheless we did it
and vendors would come in
and recalibrate our
diffusives and other equipment
so managed to get it all done
and at the time we had quite a few
reasonable young men on staff
so we had quite a lot of muscle power
at the time
and we could do this
and then can maybe do the Institute
to give up the first line of point
level for humanitarian
you comment on the background
well of course at that time
I was not in administration
I was just in research
so I didn't really have
insight into the nature of this award
I mean I was aware of the awards
and the ceremonies and so forth
and the candidates also need to be
uniformly deserving of the award
but it always seemed to me to have
a bit of a fundraising component to it
and I think probably if you asked
the people who had set up
these awards and the occasions
I think they would probably admit
that there was a fundraising component
what was the nature of the Montreal
construction of the metro
lateral
again I'm not
I didn't have a lot of familiarity
with that at the time
I know that Pauling
believes that there may be some validity
to
lateral
and he thought that
there was enough biological
plausibility that
studies should be undertaken
I don't think he had a firm opinion
that yes lateral
is definitely valuable
and treating cancer
but I think he was calling for more research
to really get to the bottom
or whether or not this was going to be useful
in cancer therapy
I didn't other than that
I really was not
to aware of the controversy at the time
but that thing actually would have
nothing to do with the investigation
not that I can remember
no
One program that I got involved with
just backtracking slightly with you and
Cameron of course
and maybe I talked about this earlier
I can't remember
Cameron was very interested in
whether or not vitamin C would
affect chemotherapy
to drug activity in the body
and he was concerned
that cancer patients who were taking
chemotherapy to drugs
that were designed to be effective
in halting the spread of cancer
or attacking the primary tumor
he didn't want those people to take
simultaneously high dose vitamin C
if the vitamin C was going to neutralize
the effectiveness of the chemotherapy
of drugs because vitamin C has some general
detoxifying capabilities
and it can interfere with certain drug action
so he was very concerned about that
and he wasn't sure
whether vitamin C would or would not
affect chemotherapy of drugs
so we set up an experiment
Alan Sheets and I
with you and Cameron and Len McPherson
to look at the effect
on fingerling trout
of chemotherapy of drugs and vitamin C
because you can monitor the movement of fish
which relates to their physiology
and biochemical activity
and I guess how they're feeling as well
so the idea was to measure fish movement
in fish that had been exposed
to drugs like methotrexate
with and with that vitamin C
to see if the vitamin C was interfering
with the drug action and in the fish
The last thing I want to ask you about today
is following relationship
where she says the cellar
so we talked about this foundation
and that means people in families
and we, in my understanding today
20 years ago
something of the controversial figure
that something we know is ever discussed
between the Institute
or the idea of vitamin H
and this was fun
and there was a close tie that it seems.
Yeah.
I think some people were aware
of Sussagalus controversial history in Japan.
I was aware that he
made at least some fortune
for motorboat racing in Japan
and that didn't really bother me much.
And that familiar with some of the other accusations
levied against him at the time
to be honest with you
I think that the magnitude of the gift
from Sussagalus Foundation
affected what we were able to do
at the Institute so dramatically
that I think most people either chose
not to think too carefully about his history
and just accept the money
which I believe was about $500,000 a year
for 10 years.
A lot of that focused on aging research
and we had a Sussagalus
aging research laboratory set up
that Porter Drive
and when Sussagalus and his entourage
would visit the Institute
it was always in a
long line of black limousines
and many, many people in dark suits
that would always accompany him.
My casual observation seemed to be
that he seemed to be a pretty
important figure and very wealthy
and I didn't really know much about him.
I met him once
and had some subsequent communication
with his son
and other functionaries
at the foundation much later.
But I didn't really,
I wasn't privy to any interactions
that took place between Pauling and Sussagalus.
Okay, thank you.